[Music]
you
it's mean look at thank you for being on
twenty minute leaders thank you for
inviting me Michael
how are you I'm actually great enjoying
taking the time off family's with me and
you know I'm worried for the world but
personally I'm doing what I can
yeah it's pretty interesting how you
know it on one hand this is you know a
crisis that we're all navigating in
different ways on the other hand it's
it's a really interesting time for
self-reflection and and taking a step
back and thinking about what it's like
I'm actually so my family is on top of
you but I have this little guy here that
just joined the family Benny hey baby
hi Benny okay yeah so he's nine weeks
old now so he's still learning that my
hand is not his favorite toy which it
definitely is right now and soon it's
gonna be the ear I see it starting and
so hopefully he'll just sit aside and
play with his a duck toy which is also a
little bit disturbing but that's okay
my dog has this fetish for toilet paper
he goes and he picks it off the thing
and it's like not the right time but is
doggy not the right time so first yeah
and it's like the worst because they
they can wrap they can rip it to so many
bits and pieces unbelievable
yes mean you are probably the most
well-connected person I can ever think
of and I mean you know just looking at
the talk show that you do on on the ICC
I JCCC is incredible and I enjoy all the
time listening to it and I'd love to
hear a little bit about the journey that
you've done from you know corporate life
to the to Stanford Business School Icahn
the shark tank of Israel just let's just
start by telling me who you are and
let's roll from there well where do I
start
yeah well I have to tell you about like
the talk show that we do now it's not
about people that we know I think we
started with a few people that we know
and it was good and we started getting
incoming people are oh I know so-and-so
and I would love to happen to come to
the program and and that's how it
happened so I think if you have
something good in hand if you're gonna
think you have a good product people are
just gonna
and it's pretty tools up for the
business world right you have a good
product you don't have to necessarily
chase partnerships and investors you all
of a sudden they start coming to you
because you have you're creating value
honestly it's true about everything it's
true about philanthropy it's true about
relationships it's true about business
that's or about everything that you do
yeah you have a good product it's
marketing itself so Who am I I was born
and raised in Israel mm-hmm see myself
with an Israeli living in Silicon Valley
I'm in the US for the past almost 17
years the past six years I'm running a
non-profit which I founded which is
called icon we're a community of people
that shared passion for hide the can
innovation coming from Israel
and together we want to see the Israeli
hi-tech thrive we do this through a
variety of events and programs and it
has been actually really challenging for
us because you cannot do events anymore
now we have a boot camp that was
supposed to come up we had two big
events we had to cancel in March I do we
invented herself and this right what
we're doing is just shifting temporarily
everything you know changing all our
content I see the same thing happening
with the startups like rethinking and
the product and what can we do after
that but hold on that's not like jump
divorce I feel now that I'm interviewing
people all the time I feel like a good
interviewee going down answer the
question which was a big question you
should ask shorter questions like
something that I can I'm interested
about everything and I only have 20
minutes so I can't it's too hard okay so
icon I did undergrad in Tel Aviv
University law counting the economics I
did the graduate degree in Stanford
Business School best years of my life
professionally an amazing amazing time
which like this atmosphere amateur
experience being the same thing now
which everything everything can happen
unbelievable people around you and and
everything everything so much so many
skills everything happen actually
interesting we reconnecting with the
class now because of this when everyone
is at home what some group was thriving
we had a reunion we actually have
already had Toby
and I spoke with people that I haven't
spoken with like so many years so a
wonderful tradition brings new
opportunity I did you know some
corporate America before I did it start
up before I was up all over the place
and I've been really happy at ICON I
think it's kind of combining many things
that I'm strong at and that I enjoy I
love spending time with entrepreneurs
and seeing like the fire and the passion
in their eyes about what they do in
their devotion and so what is the
mission of Ikon is there a sort of a
vision or a mission statement that you
go by of the value you're trying to
create I will pay forward community so
we don't ask a payment for the services
we offer but instead we ask everyone
that's part of the community to extend
to help to someone else from with the
community and we just want to see change
and we want to impact change and help
Israeli technology companies and
startups thrive and give them an unfair
advantage just because they're Israeli
and there's like a community here that
wants to support that Israeli community
here the Jewish community here and
actually people that are neither but
they understand that Israelis the
biggest technology hub outside of the US
and they want to stay relevant and
staying relevant meaning being part of
what's happening in this really tech
world and and where does that even come
from because you know going from from
corporate to startup to business school
I mean these things are not you know
it's not the traditional path to go from
that to running a non-profit so how did
this even start why are you doing this I
always did it like I always did that I
was founded I have to put like a few
sides and a few hours aside every day to
kind of help with interest to people
that I know that asking will give them
advice and help them you know I would
love to tell you that this was like a
Strad strategic plan and that was a
strategic process behind it and I set a
goal and I got to the goal but none of
this is true it's kind of happened it's
kind of there was an opportunity and I
open the window and I looked through it
and it was nice and I didn't think it's
gonna be so amazing but every step I
took there was another opportunity that
I was
it wasn't I didn't have this vision that
I could will be what it is today and it
just slowly evolved and I listened to
the people we work with and I understood
their needs and the right solutions for
them and I think the fact that we put
this as a non-profit actually was really
important to our success because when
you ask someone to help someone else and
you know you're not really making
anything out of this you just really
want to improve the situation for
everyone it's a much easier ask and and
I see so many people that don't have
time to do anything want to be part of
what we do and want to help no it's
unbelievable you know I had I had the
privilege of coming a few times to the
to the icon offices because he
graciously enough allowed me to come in
and work from there sometimes and every
single time I walk in and you have these
incredible startups sitting on a round
table with one of the most prominent
people in Silicon Valley whether they're
Jewish Israeli or not even and and the
conversation is just so fruitful and you
can see that everybody's just trying to
help each other there and there's no
transactions there's no business it's
about the relationships and about
actually helping and there's so many
little stories of things that happen and
people that connect it the way they're
just like it's you know it's endless I
think one thing that I saw this year
that happened with icon which I'm you
know particularly proud of is that
instead of just paying it forward within
the community this was the first time we
as a community paid forward outside of
the community and what we did is adopted
a Center for Entrepreneurship for youth
in the periphery of the country
periphery of Israel in the city of
nineteen votes and our founders that
most of them are centered in the center
of the country centered in the center
located in the center of the country
they're driving there and they're
mentoring the high school kids and
helping them how we do it with the
nonprofit that's called unistream the
minute so we're not inventing we were
just connected our skills and our
community with someone who's already
doing this and I think it's amazing it's
so rewarding it's wonderful so now and
now most recently you're very very well
known in Israel as a shark I went deep
very well-known I was it's like you know
yes men in
circles that I run with you're very very
well known so it's all be before you
shouldn't do it you won't be able to go
on the street nobody's ever gonna you
know people why can't I see it's not
happening they said none of them care
not well everything's all fine I don't
want to say it here about how people
scared me but I don't feel I'm well
known but it's not the thing it's not
anything yes I won the Israel I'm the
cast on the Israeli shark tank we filmed
it about a little more than a year ago
last January and it's just starting to
air it started during January they
stopped the season with 14 episodes I
think and they were in the audience out
7 yeah so happy season coming up now
because of the situation they changed
the schedule sure which i think is cool
and it was an amazing experience
really like taking everything I learned
from the high tech world and from the
technological startups because we saw
startups there from every vertical right
with dreams people with ideas and
bringing what I learned to other
verticals to someone that developed like
this gadget for a hair salon or someone
that has a breastfeeding pump so many
many different ideas or many verticals
people that come from all over the
country people they just actually have a
dream have a passion have this sparkle
in their eyes and they dare to go and
try to make a change and and and taking
this chance being on you know informal
the Sharks being on TV and doing
something with their dreams and I got a
lot from meeting those people I really
enjoyed that and sitting with the fellow
sharks right definitely it was an
amazing experience and a lot of these
fellow sharks are also heavily involved
with icon and with other things that
you're doing so it's really it's a
continuation of your relationship with
them I felt lucky I mean we were five of
us out of the only the only one I didn't
know before only a guide I haven't met
him before I met him just before the
show but he's the only one I didn't work
with yeah you know it was just sitting
with friends and we work with all the
time and I think it showed because we
know each other and we have a good
chemistry offline so I think it showed
online so and it's part of the show so
how many how many different you know
ideas or pitches did you see throughout
the filming of the show I think
you seen about a hundred okay so I wanna
I want to get you this one the one thing
you noticed of those 100 the difficulty
given advice to everybody you would go
back in time you would give them or
would it be there were many different
things but I think the one thing that
probably the mistake that most
entrepreneurs do not just on the show
they have an idea they think they they
have an idea something technical
something not but they're not sure you
know but they don't do enough validation
and they don't know if there's actually
a problem so fine you found something
but is there a problem that you're
solving is the problem big enough let me
not dig it up is it painful enough that
people are willing to pay for the
solution maybe there's a problem but
nobody really cares about it people are
willing to pay for the solution and are
there enough people that have this
problem and are willing to pay for it so
I think people don't do enough research
and they don't do it not validation
which is not just important for yourself
because you want to know you're going
the right path but it's also extremely
important when you go and want to speak
with an investor you have to have not
just a hunch but like research that
you've done you know whatever
indications you have that your solution
is not just technical technically
possible but is also addressing a
problem that enough people are willing
to pay for I I think this goes along to
say a similar line to an advice that I
keep hearing from a lot of investors
about remaining humble and remaining you
know sincere about what you also don't
know and I think that one of the issues
that that that the startup world faces
is that a lot of people get so excited
about their idea in their solution that
it seems almost impossible to them that
they could be wrong or that there's
another way to do something and they
fall in love with this notion that
they've created for themselves and I
definitely know that when I when I'll
have the chance to build something of my
own I always want to remain you know
humble enough to be to be challenging
myself and having others challenge me no
I don't think it's just about humility I
think it's about you have to have facts
to back up your hunches and you know if
you see the part being very humble you
say you know I don't know this
I don't know this go look up for the
answers don't come and ask for my money
before you actually research this that
is just about admitting what you don't
know it's about trying to find the
answers that makes a lot of sense yes I
mean you over the years that icon and
before and what starts you've seen so
many different industries and so many
different startups what are you excited
about what what really gets you excited
and makes you passionate is Devon months
old so I think the one thing you know
it's not a vertical or an idea I'm
passionate about the people I'm inside
this is the one thing that I liked in
the Sharks is one thing that I enjoy
like gonna make day-to-day basis with
icon I love working with people that
really are passionate about what they do
they have this sparkle in their eyes and
it could be a cyber product and it could
be a consumer product you could be as
something medical
could be something become anything
anything when the people you know when
they impacting change changing the world
changing a company improving something
and they're passionate about what
they're doing and their customers love
it I enjoy spending time with them you
know personally I also I love the power
of the community and you know with you
in the stream and how we took what we
have as a community and we impacted
impacted this you know change and help
in the periphery of the country that was
really I was passionate about that too
and that's that's wonderful
really using leveraging the power of the
community so I think I'm passionate
about leveraging powerful communities
and in fashion changing that yeah so now
more of a personal question for me you
know I'm just starting and paving my way
through through this experience and Palo
Alto Anna and I'm so lucky that we did
we got to meet quite a few times and
from this relationship over over this
last year so looking down the road what
what advice would you give me as I'm
just starting my career here in all
different spectrums what are some things
that I should be keeping in mind as I go
through this path oh yeah I guess it
depends what you want to go what would
you
do what's your pad I think now it's like
a very interesting time this is an
opportunity to sit and reflect this is
not a time to start a new business so we
put that aside but it's a time to
research business ideas that you have
it's time to upgrade relationships it's
really time to learn if you just started
a business or a business and you can
weather the storm time to work on your
infrastructure all those projects right
never got to now you have time to do
them and look at that so this is like
the sign of the times job brainstorm I
mean nobody knows what's gonna be after
right venture you know we're gonna all
have ideas but you know this never
happened before right now you know I
think the caliber with the circumstances
that we have around educated guesses but
still guesses you just be ready for the
day after no you know I said one of the
things that I've been thinking about not
necessarily starting my own thing right
now but you know I I did a wonderful a
venture capital class with and from
floodgate at Stanford and one of the
things that we kept iterating over is
how hard it is to change consumer
behavior and how rare it is that we have
an opportunity to radically change how
people act and consume stuff on a day to
day basis and you know this whole thing
that's happening right now
it's one big consumer shift whether it's
for online communication or our
relationship norms or working from home
it's it's pretty pretty incredible it's
mean before it before we finish I want
to ask you my last question and I'm
putting you a little bit on the spot but
what are three words that you think best
describe you someone else how would you
like how would you like somebody else to
describe you okay oh I should have
thought about this you people time how
do we have time yeah ten seconds I like
honest I like I like to describe as
honest I think transparency and you know
and being honest about about why you do
things it is I think this is important
honesty I think oil tea trustworthiness
loyalties is kind of a different part of
that someone you can count on music
that are important to me what else I
don't know how would you describe me
give me one more
I mean do you know what curious curious
I think we share that and I think
there's you know why you you interview
people and I enjoy doing that - I wanna
mean I told you before we started we
interviewed someone yesterday it was
supposed to be 30 minutes ended up being
an hour and then after an hour I was
like you know we have to finish the show
was it like show but we cut off the show
and we continued just chatting with him
for another hour
so I would take curious I want to know
why I'm curious so I'll add a fourth one
just because it due to this conversation
exactly people first I see that icon I
said what are you doing Athena stream
and and shark tank and in this
conversation so yes I mean thank you for
everything that you're doing thank you
for this friendship and this
relationship that were forming over the
years and best of luck thank you for
inviting me Michael and stay healthy
stay home of course